we live in a world where Innovation is
the lifeblood of progress and artificial
intelligence stands as the driving force
that powers our Innovations the top 10
companies of today are not just shaping
the future but they are sculpting it
with a Precision that was once nothing
more than a science fiction these
companies are not just Titans of the
industry they are The Architects of
tomorrow where machines think love learn
and adapt alongside humans forever
altering the landscape of Business
Health Care Transportation and Beyond
artificial intelligence has become the
transformator force that redefines how
we live work and interact with our world
at its core AI is the amalgamation of
data algorithms and computational power
harness to unlock insights solve complex
problems and automate task that were
once considered impossible welcome to
Simply LA's YouTube channel today we
bring you the top 10 AI companies for
2024 that are leading the charge have
the potential to spearhead Innovation
and are pushing the boundaries of what's
possible but before we begin if these
are the type of videos you'd like to
watch then a free subscription to our
channel would be beneficial and that
Bell icon next to the Subscribe button
would notify you when we post that said
if you are an aspiring artificial
intelligence engineer with at least one
year domain experience and this looking
for an online training and certification
program from the prestigious
universities in collaboration with
leading experts to have the most robust
foundational skills knowledge and what
it takes to become the best then search
no more simply learns postgraduate
program and artificial intelligence from
peria University in collaboration with
IBM should be the right choice for more
details on this program please visit our
home page or simply click on the link in
the description box below with that in
mind over to our training hey everyone
so without further delay let's get
started with the first one on the list
Nvidia Nvidia ranks among the top AI
companies chiefly recognized for its
groundbreaking working developing gpus
are graphical processing units crucial
for AI and deep learning applications
these gpus are known for their parallel
processing capabilities vital for
training and deploying deep learning
neural networks across various sectors
like healthcare autonomous vehicles and
finance Nvidia Relentless commitment to
a I research and development has played
a pivotal role in advancing AI
technology accessibility through its
innovative hardware and software
Solutions including Cuda and tensor RT
Nvidia continues to significantly
contribute to the progression and
widespread adoption of artificial
intelligence the career prospects with
Nvidia look highly promising in the near
future of the Year 2024 the average
salary of an eii engineer working with
Nvidia in United States of America can
earn from a range of $100,000 to2
$100,000 based on the experience in
India the average salary of an AI
engineer ranges from 6 lakhs to 25 lakhs
perom based on their experience moving
ahead we have Microsoft Microsoft stands
as one of the largest AI companies
consistently at the Forefront of AI
research and development the company's
Focus spans a wide area of AI
applications including natural language
processing computer vision and
reinforcement learning Microsoft Azure
AI platform offers robot tools and
services that Empower businesses to
integrate AI to their operations
seamlessly furthermore Microsoft
research continuously pushes the
boundaries of AI through groundbreaking
projects and collaborations with leading
academic institutions this commitment to
Innovation combined with the cloud
computing resources has made Microsoft a
major contributor to ai's Evolution
enabling countless organizations to
harness the power of artificial
intelligence in their products and
services the average salary of a an EI
engineer working with Microsoft in
United States of America ranges from
$100,000 to
$200,000 based on their experience and
their caliber now ai engineer salaries
in Microsoft in India ranges from 10
lakhs to 30 lakhs per anom based on
their experience next ahead is IBM IBM
is undeniably a leading force in the
world of artificial intelligence known
for its pioneering work in AI research
and application the company's AI
initiatives and Compass a wide spectrum
of developing Advanced machine learning
algorithms to Cutting Edge AI driven
solutions for Industries like healthcare
finance and cyber security IBM's Watson
platform with its natural language
understanding and cognitive Computing
capabilities has set new standards in AI
driven decision support systems
additionally IBM research consistently
produces groundbreaking AI Innovations
such as advancements and Quantum
Computing which hold the potential to
revolutionalize AI capabilities IBM
continuous commitment to AI research and
its practical applications significantly
contributes to the ongoing Evolution and
widespread adoption of artificial
intelligent Technologies the average
salary of AI engineer working with IBM
can expect a decent salary in USA
ranging from $80,000 to $180,000 per in
India the average salary of an AI
engineer working with IBM can range from
8 lakhs to 30 lakhs per ROM based on
experience next inth list is open a
open AI has rapidly emerged as one of
the foremost AI companies Renown for its
pioneering work in the field of
artificial intelligence the organization
is dedicated to pushing the boundaries
of AI research and development while
emphasizing ethical and responsible AI
deployment open AI focuses on developing
Advanced machine learning models such as
chat gpt3 and its successes which have
demonstrated exceptional capabilities in
natural language understanding and
generation these models find
applications in a wide range of
industries from content generation to
Virtual assistance and language
translation open AI open source approach
and Partnerships with various
stakeholders have played a pivotal role
in democratizing AI making it more
accessible and fostering collaboration
across the AI Community through its
Innovative Technologies and commitment
to ethical AI open AI continues to be
major contributor to the advancement and
responsible use of artificial
intelligence the average salary of an AI
engineer working with open AI in America
can expect a salary ranging from
$120,000 to $200,000 per am in India
open a compensates their AI Engineers
with handsome salary packages ranging
from 8 lakhs to 25 lakhs perom based on
their experience proceeding ahead we
have Google Google stands as a prominent
leader amongst AI companies with a
multifaceted commitment to advancing
artificial intelligence the company
leverages AI across its products and
services ranging from Google Search to
YouTube recommendation algorithms to
Google assistant and self-driving
technology through its subsidiary wayo
Google's Deep Mind subsidary has made
remarkable strides in reinforcement
learning and Healthcare applications
additionally Google brain the company's
AI research division continuously
Pioneers new machine learning techniques
and architectures by fostering an
environment of innovation and
exploration Google has significantly
contributed to ai's progress and its
open source projects and research
Publications have expert collaboration
and advancements across the AI Community
further solidifying its position as a
major player in the field of artificial
intelligence the average salary of an AI
engineer working with Google in America
can expect a handsome salary range from
$250,000 to $400,000 perum based on
experience in India the average salary
of an AI engineer working with Google
can expect an annual compensation
ranging from 25 laks to 45 laks per anom
based on their experience now next is
apple apple is a prominent player in the
AI landscape recognized for its
commitment to integrating artificial
intelligence into its products and
services additionally Apple employs AI
in image and speech recognition
enhancing user experiences in areas like
photography and accessibility the
company harnesses AI for applications
like Siri where natural language
processing and machine learning enable
voice controll interactions additionally
Apple employs AI in image and speech
recognition enhancing user experiences
in areas like photography and
accessibility
Apple's focus on privacy is also
noteworthy as it prioritizes user data
protection in AI applications although
Less publicized in AI research compared
to some peers Apple's emphasis on user
Centric AI experiences and its Hardware
software integration have made it a
significant contributor to the evolution
of AI driven Technologies in the
consumer tech industry the average
salary of an AI engineer working with
apple can expect an annual salary
ranging from $250,000 to $400,000 per
AMOM in India an AI engineer working
with apple can expect an average salary
ranging from 40 lakhs to 80 lakhs perim
based on experience moving ahead we have
Meta Meta formally known as Facebook
stands as a prominent AI company with a
wide reaching influence in the field the
company's work spans various AI domains
including natural language processing
computer vision and recommendation
systems meta employs AI extensively in
its social media platforms optimizing
content delivery and personalization for
billions of users the development of AI
driven virtual reality and augmented
reality Technologies through Ulus
further underscores meta's AI Ambitions
moreover the company actively
contributes to AI research publishing
papers and open- sourcing AI Frameworks
with its vast user base and investments
in AI research and development meta
plays a pivotal role in shaping the
future of AI by driving Innovations in
social networking immersive Technologies
and V
the average salary of an AI engineer
ranges from $150,000 to $250,000 perom
in USA and in India the average salary
of an AI engineer working with meta
ranges from 20 lakhs to 40 lakhs perum
based on experience next ahead is Deep
Mind Deep Mind has firmly established
itself as a leading AI company known for
its pioneering work in the realm of
artificial intelligence the company
specializes in cutting Ed research in
reinforcement learning and has achieved
remarkable success including the
development of alpha go which defeated
human go Champions deep Minds
contributions extend to healthcare where
it utilizes AI to analyze medical data
and assistant diagnosis and treatment
planning its ongoing research and
diverse and Innovative algorithms
continue to push the boundaries of AI
capabilities deep mind's commitment to
ethical Ai and its collaboration with
the broader scientific Community have
made it a major force in shaping the
future of AI and and its responsible
integration into various Industries the
average salary of an AI engineer in
America working with deep mind can
expect around $150,000 to
$250,000 based on experience and in
India an AI engineer working with deep
mine can expect around 95 lakhs to 1 CR
per an and the next on the list is data
robot data robot is a prominent AI
company that focuses on automating the
machine learning process making AI
accessible to a broader audience the
company's platform empowers
organizations to build deploy and manage
machine learning models efficiently even
without extensive data science expertise
by democratizing AI data robot has
played a crucial role in accelerating AI
adoption across various industries from
Finance to healthcare its Automated
machine learning algorithms and AI
driven insights enable businesses to
make datadriven decisions and enhance
their operations data robot's
contribution to AI lies in simplifying
and democratizing the complex world of
machine learning enabling organizations
of all sizes to harness the power of AI
for improved decision making and
competitiveness now coming into salaries
in the United States of America the
average salary of an AI engineer working
with data robot can range from $250,000
to $400,000 per anom coming into India
the AI engineer working with data robot
in India can expect an average salary
ranging from 30 lakhs to 60 lakhs per
anom based on experience and the last
one on the list sap
sap is a leading AI company Renown for
its work in Enterprise software
Solutions the company leverages
artificial intelligence to enhance its
software offerings optimizing business
processes and data analytics for
organizations worldwide saps AI power
applications SP various domains
including Supply Chain management
finance and customer relationship
management by integrating AI driven
insights and automation into its suit of
products sap helps businesses make
smarter decisions and streamline
operations the company's substantial
customer base and extensive industry
Partnerships further underscore its
major contribution to the widespread
adoption of AI in Enterprise settings
making it a pivotal player in the aid
driven transformation of businesses and
industries now coming into salaries the
average salary of an AI engineer working
with sap in America can range from
$200,000 to $300,000 per AMOM based on
experience and coming into India the
average salary of an AI engineer ranges
from from 25 lakhs to 45 lakhs perom
based on their experience and with that
we have reached to the end of this video
on top 10 eii companies for 20124 but
before we wrap up the session if you are
a complete beginner and need a perfect
online training program that caters your
beginning steps towards a successful
career in artificial intelligence and
machine learning then take a look at the
simply learns Master's course in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning for more details on this course
head straight to our homepage or simply
use the link in the descript description
box below this link should redirect you
to the official course landing page that
will give you a complete overview of the
course being offered that's it thank you
for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply upskill and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here